/バン\
みんな！大変だ！
新しいメッセージが届いたぞ！
/バン\
最近さぁ
こういうメッセージが多いんすよ。
コメント。
『遊戯王のウルトラレーンを燃やすと爆発するらしいです！やってみてください！』
はあ？
『はじめしゃちょー！ヨーグルトにメントスを入れるとものすごいことになります！やってみてください！』
あん？
あのさあ、
こういろいろ何か
やってみてくださいやってみてください
って言われるのは
とてもありがたいんですよ！ホントに。
すごい…いろいろ言われるんですけど、
僕はですね！
そういう一個一個全部さぁ…
………やります。
まあ面白いと思ったやつだけですけどね。
やってみたいです。
やってみたいんですけど…
ホントに僕がなんかあの…
やりたいなって思ったことだけは
やってみようと思います。
はい、というわけで今回はですね。
卵―
また卵ですよ。
今回はこのタマ…あっ
あの…
叩かれないように言っておこう。
賞味期限は切れております。（もったいない）
この卵をな、
今ここに水をちょっと入れてあるんだけど…
卵をな、
水の入ったお皿に
こう入れて、
/ポトン\
これをレンジでチンすると
爆発するっていう情報を得たんで、
やってみようと思います。
これもなぁ…ちょっとなぁ…
信ぴょう性に欠けるんだよなぁ…
デマが多いからさぁ、
ちょっといろいろと…
いろいろもう何を信じていいか分かんないんスよ。
やってみようと思います！
はい！
というわけで早速ね。
北に花火を打ち上げようと思います。
はい。
一応お皿に卵・水を入れてあります。
じゃあもうやっちゃうからね。
俺はね、まだね、一応信じてないんだよ。
ホントになるのかっていう…
/ガッタン\
こんなことで
こんなことになったら
もう世の中のものなんでも爆発するからね。
/バタン\
/カチッ\
うぅ…
うぅ~！ううぅぅ～！
オイ。
ならないぞ。
デマかぁ～。
こんな…だって
こんなことで爆発とかしないっすよ、
普通。
最近デマが多いんだよな、マジで。
今回こういう失敗になっちゃったんですけども、
まあ、
こういう
今回はメッセージ性のある動画を作れたと
思ってます。
やっぱこういうデマ情報を流すのは…
あんまりよろしくないな。
また実際にマネしちゃって、
こう…
いろいろ危ないこともあるし…
あのー…
/ドカン\
うわぁぁぁっ☆
※この実験は本当に危険です。はじめしゃちょーはものすごく運が良かったんです。最悪の場合、爆発事故にもなりかねませんし、家が燃えたり、電子レンジの近くにいる人が爆発に巻き込まれたりすることによる死亡の危険性もありますので、絶対にマネしてはいけません。
※補足：電子レンジには金属を入れても爆発、大火事の危険があるのでやってはいけませんよ☆
あぁーのぉー…
/どっかぁぁぁん\
うっ
わあああぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ！！
/ピーッ\
/ピーッ \
…本当でした。
あぁぁー！
たまご！
タマゴ！
あぁぁぁ～っ
ああああぁぁぁぁ…